quick I want to start with a confession
and an apology I did trained as an
economist but ever since then I've been
trying to become a decent person so I
hope and I'm gonna do fairly rapidly
because of the time here
we picked human resources because it was
an issue that had come up in in so many
of your lists of concerns and I listened
to Elizabeth yesterday so I started with
a problem and I was reminded over lunch
that if you look at what how you define
your problems here's a list of them but
it's not complete because it's not only
in some countries too few workers the
wrong kinds are unskilled but as I
learned over lunch from our colleague
from Ghana they're in the wrong places
distribution so many different countries
many different issues not just doctors
and nurses huge differences across
countries there's some that are close
and some that are far from solving these
problems and huge commitments to scale
this up you probably know this from
within your own company country
certainly at the global level their
grand promises made Gordon Brown has
announced that he would stand by adding
a million more health workers for Africa
we sorted through the back channels said
have you done the math can you afford to
do that how long it's going to take and
the answer was oops we didn't do that
what they said proudly as well you
should be proud of us because Gordon
originally was going to say 4 million
and we talked them down from four to one
now unfunded liabilities is is a concept
I've borrowed from the investment world
namely when promises are made
commitments are made programs are rolled
up rolled out has anybody thought about
what the implications of that are going
to be so one example is that meeting the
Millennium Development challenge goal
goals which which are terrifically
important everybody signed up but if we
do meet them will we be able to have the
health workers in place to actually
carry out in a long-term sustainable
basis what that implies so that's why
I've been emphasizing that does it all
add up what's the cost can it be net and
what I want to get into a little bit
here this is big
topic we've only got a little bit of
time so we could spend another week
Elizabeth on this is that sometimes
simple calculations can lead you far
astray if you don't take into account
some things in the case of health
workers you do have to train them from
from the ground up and and you have more
health workers in place that induces
more services that induce more cost so
more careful analysis need in every
country for itself and the countries
here have done that I have learned but
it's an ongoing thing that we always
need to go on doing by the way I would
add when you come back here for a GH li
did I say that right - you should also
advise this country about how to fix its
health problems so a little bit about
some efforts to help give you the tools
to think about these problems there are
some global task forces many people here
from the U of them I'm not going to
dwell on them migration is a huge issue
the brain drain I'm talking to several
of you there are efforts to try and do
things that the receiving countries
would undertake some countries I think
Norway is committing to for every worker
that comes to them to pay back the
equivalent to go to the countries that's
sending there's some other efforts but
don't hold your breath and I know how
wise and experienced you are these
efforts are not necessarily going to
change the challenges that we all face
all the time
similarly on pre-service training and
building up on that I'm gonna focus on
the costs and financing and that's an
area where there are a couple of steps
forward that might be helpful really
that build on learning from what the
countries here and other countries are
doing so once again as Rob said what
this is really about this week is
getting the tremendous experience and
thoughts that are in each of your heads
- all of your heads including I hope
mine and I a couple of things that will
be available to you by email there's a
paper that reviews some of the recent
experience of that
I have a paper copy here it'll be
available by email and there's another
paper that's what countries can do now
it brings together some experiences
actually is the title is 29 things that
countries can do now it's been a big
seller and you'll you'll have it and so
I asked somebody why do you think this
is sold so well it's so it's free it's
free but I mean why is it been so
popular said y29
you know why not 30 or 24 or 26 so
there's a list of issues and ways to
tackle them like the fiscal space issue
you want to have more health workers got
to pay for them that means that your
your government budget has to have room
how do you tackle the Minister of
Finance to get more fiscal space more
space out of the fiscal pie to make room
for that I'm going to focus mainly on
this this idea of a simple analytical
tool which is also available for free
open source to to everybody and I'll
leave you with how you can get your your
hands on it and take it home so there
are a couple of things here you can take
home and use and this thing called the
resource retirement requirement tool
it's basically just a set of
spreadsheets so it's not a big black box
it's not a big model it's not attempting
to it's not pretentious but just saying
that if you think about a couple of
elements that have to be thought through
and then have connections with each
other when you're thinking about how
many how many health workers of
different cadres in different regions
can do we think we need how much does
that cost what are the implications of
how does that add up to and I'm going to
talk a little bit about these tools not
only as devices to clear one's mind but
also as devices to help with making the
case to whoever else whether it's the
ministers ministries of Finance or
others need to be convinced and this
little simple device has three main
parts to it one of which estimates
resource requirements for public sector
human resource
accounting for what's going on the
private sector then the second part on
pre-service and then the third part
which brings it all together and
estimates a gap between the required and
yet available funds anybody used this or
familiar with this tool because
something like 18 countries have already
although it's relatively newly developed
or expressed a lot of interest in and
it's something that that is deliberately
simple so that anybody can learn it and
use it and with their own assumptions
not black box no mystery to it at all
now if you saw the first Star Wars movie
it was the famous moment when Harrison
Ford and whatever gaggle of strange
creatures he was with in his spaceship
with was trying to escape some pursuers
and we all waited on the edge of our
seats and then he pressed a button and
went into hyperspace
that's an old movie but it's been around
for a while Hetzer changed my world
we're about to go into hyperspace
because of the time and I'm not going to
present properly this slides that follow
I'm going to go through them as though
they were hyperspace fast but you will
have you'll have the whole presentation
and it's just to break down each of
these components and say what goes on
one introduces data or assumptions you
have data
great on your country right if you don't
what assumptions do you want to start
from got to make assumptions so be
explicit about them that's that that's
the logic here let's bring out all of
the stuff that that we're making
assumptions about the country the HRH
cadre doctors nurses and so on
geographic area the whole bit just lay
it all out there let the machine do the
arithmetic but the thinking has to come
from from us and and then construct
scenarios where we're not sure about the
assumptions let's vary them does it make
a difference if we were wrong in our
assumptions and varied them from what we
thought it might be to what it might be
an extreme does that make a difference
in the outcome or not that's the whole
bit about scenario analysis looking at
all the usual things are there bonuses
being offered I
number country's wrestle with how do you
get healthcare workers to go to remote
regions if you offer bonuses are they
location deployment or performance
related and so on lots more there you
then generate results that enable you
look at what's going to happen to your
healthcare cost this is just a simple
application in this case during that
time period the costs are going to
increase by approximately 50% looking at
looking at those numbers this is just a
hypothetical
application real application probably
have more variation the second component
is the pre-service training component
and that that turns out in discussions
with people like Gordon Brown to be
something that doesn't often adequately
get thought of it takes a long time to
train doctors and nurses takes a long
time to upgrade existing health workers
you all know that and and that is costly
and there's a question of how much
budget you've got and and where you
start from lots more to say there but
again here we are in hyperspace we're
just giving you the overview you can
study it going to take it home again you
can do scenarios you can vary things you
pull together all the people that you
have who have the knowledge available
the evidence and the gaps in the
evidence and say well let's lay it all
out let's make some assumption and and
then let's try changes and see what
difference it makes again
you can generate outputs like this which
tells you the how your costs are going
to increase this is basically dollars
how your costs are going to increase as
the from expansion of the current level
and additional beyond your capacity
level the third component is estimating
the gap the ability to fund based on
what you need and what you got what you
need today and tomorrow and future years
and what your budget is likely to do
again you can check those assumptions
you can say what if we're less
successful in convincing the Ministry of
Finance to give us a bit more or what if
we're more successful what difference
would that make to us what
we assume about donors or to Exuma bout
GDP actually the logic here is how much
of GDP is being captured in taxes by
government what share that is going to
health and what share that is available
for spending on health workers and and
similarly in terms of households spend
spending starts at one level and and
what it is available for health
scenarios and and results so here is the
results showing a gap how much is needed
and how much is likely to be available
over time again this you know the the
the information that you generate from a
very simple tool like this is only as
good as the effort you put in isn't it's
just doing the math it's just a little
simple calculator so it's not that it's
going to change one's world as one
thinks about it but it can be useful to
have information like this and I
remember talking to one Minister of
Finance who said he'd be a lot more
friendly a lot more presupposed to give
more resources to health if he felt
there was solid analysis being presented
to them maybe that's not true in every
country but it does seem to come up now
this whole thing can then be used in
feedback you can say all right we got
various scenarios we got fergus out
outputs now let's take those and go back
and and ask well the plans that we
thought we committed ourselves to the
plans that the president announced last
year don't really add up so let's go
back and see how we would have to change
those plans to make them this is what
Gordon Brown should have done we're
working on him but he's only got a short
life left before
so there's the potential doing feedback
and also monitoring overtime so you do
you do this sort of exercise once you go
back to it and again and it's not very
complicated just simple spreadsheets
easy to to learn and nothing complicated
hidden it is not it is not a forecasting
tool it's not going to tell you what's
going to happen tomorrow it's not for
quote-unquote manpower planning which is
to go in great detail and say in the you
know in the Dodoma district over in the
great eastern swamp we're going to need
15 nurses of this kind and four nurses
of that kind that kind of detailed
planning very hard some would say cannot
be done certainly no pretensions that
this kind of simple analysis can do that
it's also not a replication of other
tools but it certainly draws on them
quite explicitly that some of which you
you may have heard it's been used in a
number of countries in Peru they did of
course for 30 leaders in the ministry of
health and then prepare to their next
there'd certainly as they were preparing
their decentralized health insurance
system they used this tool and fit it to
their special needs mozambique had
already done their own cost estimates
separately but they were not so sure how
robust those estimates were so they used
this tool they were very happy to find
similar results might not have happened
that way
but it gave them and their their
partners donors a little bit more
confidence more donor money came in in
Uganda similar kind of experience they
had worked on various pieces of human
resources development separately and but
had not taught tackled the cost and
financing so they use this analysis it
and it's always country owned and
country driven it's not something that's
being done by outsiders so and it's
something that within the health sector
the leaders and and the teams can do for
themselves
and and they had a fairly happy result
I'm not trying to sell you as a tool
because it's free but I am now going to
finish and with some questions and what
are the toughest problems that you're
facing and managing your human resources
for health I list a few issues there
what solutions are you considering are
there lessons from your experience than
have helped others and how can yell and
others help I also want to close by
saying that I'm suggesting you reflect
on this material at two different levels
one is about human resources for health
issues and this tool can it be helpful
can it be adapted to be helpful
etc but secondly second level think
about whether uses of simple analytical
tools whatever they are whatever your
subject they are on can be useful and
what are their pitfalls what are their
pluses what are their minuses do they
help make the case even if they haven't
given you new insights do they give you
new insights and and can they if they're
not carefully used can they be
misleading or can they be harmful